- What are you doing?
- Why you leavin' him hangin', man?
- Dude, he's just like,
this is great for the vlog and I'm like,
if I have to wake up in like an hour.
Fuck me!
Get me out of here, what?!
(hip hop music)
You know I'm starting my 101's
but I also realized I'm like,
what I'm trying to
accomplish may actually work
in smaller formats.
I did one two days ago,
went really really really well.
And I had a meeting
so basically, literally, every
if anything happens with a cancellation,
I'm gonna try to do like shotgun,
you know,
I need to accomplish
people really realizing
how deep I am in the business, right?
So I think
I think one thing I'm
spending a lot of time on is
thinking about how good I
am at documenting content,
and what that creates, right?
So for me,
I'm spending anywhere
between 12 and 14 hours
a day on VaynerMedia.
But if you're an employee,
and the only thing I can show in that
in my day is my public
keynote or my public interview
that I do, it becomes propaganda
almost too much in the other direction.
So I want to really just figure out
how to get people to
start communicating to me
for real, because I think
the biggest misconception that I'm sure of
that I'm gonna spend almost all my time on
is the following.
I think about life as alternatives.
Right?
To me, everything is,
what's the alternative?
I'm not really ideological or
and I'm not very like
making pretend.
And so I think that
I have enormous heart and excitement about
what this place's intent is,
because I really, really,
really think that's
the most important thing.
And then I think about
what stems from my intent,
all the way down to execution.
And it's remarkable to me
how many things I think are broken.
Like, an enormous amount.
But that comes with scale, and comes with
the reality of the business.
The question becomes,
how do you get that proper?
To me, I feel comfortable,
as you can even tell in here
and I'll even answer anything,
it's funny how comfortable,
even at the mercy of
not having deep
relationships with all of you
knowing what you're gonna
say when you go out there,
and knowing how fast rumors can spread,
I'm still far more comfortable
sitting in this room, talking to you
for an hour about stuff
than I would be sending
a company-wide email
where tone is always 100 percent,
that's why we do so many videos.
I'm so scared to send company-wide emails,
'cause an adjective or two or just
literally humans filter based on their
own internal feelings, right?
You literally just, you know.
So,
there's just a lot of
great stuff going on,
I'm very confident,
and I feel like I've never
had a better grasp on
the things that are on super fire,
the things that are an annoyance,
the things that are
but for me,
I just want to get into
the hotline business.
Right?
What I keep thinking about every day is
I need to create a hotline which is
the biggest vulnerability for me when I
engage at scale, is I don't know
where you are between boy that cries wolf
and I'm quitting tomorrow.
That has been my unbelievable fascination
over the last seven years
'cause everybody
communicates so differently.
And we're doing a lot, and I'm doing a lot
to try to have a sense
but even on a one-to-one level,
there's things that I haven't been able to
totally figure out.
So, I guess the biggest
thing I'd like you to
leave here with, whether
you've been here for
three weeks, or whether
almost six years is
I've basically made an
interesting commitment
to myself somewhere
halfway through last year
which is
I don't want anybody to leave this place
without going through me.
Here's why.
I'll get you a better job outside of here
than you'll get for yourself.
And that would make me feel awesome
because I'm so grateful
for you ever working here
in the first place.
And so, to that extreme,
I think we can really create something,
'cause I've really just watched the people
that have voluntarily left the company
over the last six months,
like, this is what I do on my vacations,
I went through it and
I was like, fuck, man.
Seven of these temp people I
have a whole lot of heart for,
some I just didn't get to know
or sometimes people come in
before I get to meet them,
you know, life, right?
But,
that is the intent of our organization.
That's what we're gonna build out.
To me, the happiness meter in this company
is very simple.
The closer you are to
me, the happier you are
at this company.
It's just very basic.
Because those people just know
they're just
they're not drinking the kool-aid,
they just see the details.
Are we still number three?
Hey bro!
- [Man] Yeeaahh.
- [Man] So we're releasing pod sessions,
audio and video on Friday.
But we want to drive back to
the podcast to Monday,
also introducing Monday's podcast which is
going to be the fireside chat with Ryan
- But also want to jump in before this and
make sure you checked out Friday's.
I know how the weekends can get.
Friday's pod sessions number two,
these pod sessions are straight fire,
I'm very excited about it.
So if you're just joining
me for the first time ever,
or you didn't get a chance to listen to
Friday's pod sessions, go
back and check that out.
Enjoy the show.
- This is just us, technically on beta.
So I want to make sure I can
- Vlog!
VaynerBeta, literally the
greatest use of your money.
(bell ding)
(laughs)
- 100 percent.
- It's actually true.
You know what's super crazy?
- 100 percent.
- 4D's is amazing
but the audience in the vlog,
the number one thing that they should do,
they all want to work,
I get a million emails every day.
We have a company, we have a division,
it's VaynerBeta.
It's for
how low can they get in for?
- We've got some entry level products,
like marketing automation, user flows,
we've got
mini-campaigns that we do
- They're very basic.
- 20, 25K
- I fuckin' knew it.
- But you'll get real,
real tangible results.
Not having to sign up for us for six
- Alright enough of the commercial.
Vlog, VaynerBeta.
(laughs)
Alright, what's going on.
Gabe, you see this?
And I'm doing a pop up in L.A.
(laughs)
(modern hip hop music)
When you get traded, you get traded.
Thank you, brother.
That's exactly right,
I'm just looking for the
the email or the text or
the DM four years later,
saying, that quote got me or
that talk changed my trajectory.
Thank you.
Just had a three hour meeting
on a private plane
with my chief client officer.
She's running back to the airport,
flying back.
Life's gotten weird.
(laughs)
Really really
Hello hello!
- Gary, what's up, man?
- How are you?
- Chris Powers.
- Chris, such a pleasure.
Thank you so much for
being a part of this.
I don't take this lightly,
it's the first time I'm trying it,
with kind of like the conference people,
and this is gonna be a lot of fun.
I already was laughing, I'm like
I've been trying to think
about how to market this,
because there's no way
in hell I'm gonna stay
for just the limit allocated.
You know?
The organizers, my people, my agent
they're like, alright two
hours you can bounce that
I'm like,
but I can stay three hours, right?
And they're like, yeah.
So like, I'm excited, this
is a real fun format for me.
The 4D's thing that we've been doing
has been a lot of fun,
but I'm only in there for like an hour and
having a smaller group and I think
tonight's gonna be a lot of fun.
- [Man] It's so funny.
Like, I grew up idolizing Kobe.
- [Gary V] Yes.
- [Man] You're equal as
far as who I idolize.
If I was here with Kobe right now
I would be freaking out.
I feel like you do such a good job,
this is not kissing your ass,
I'll probably never see you
again the rest of my life.
(laughs)
- I hope we do.
- I hope so as well.
You do such a good job at connecting to me
and I feel like each one of us think this.
I thought I had a personal
connection with you
but I definitely don't.
And it's fine.
- You know what it's called?
It's called paying attention.
- How you're just real.
You're just real.
- Well yeah.
- I don't feel
like I'm in front of you right now.
And I mean that in
- Like I'm still on screen?
- Let's put it this way
- I get,
dude
you'll love this.
When I have dinner with a Jets player,
who isn't even a big player,
I feel the same exact way.
It's like whatever you're into, right?
It's super cool.
- It's the way you connect
let's put it this way.
When I watch you on TV, I
feel like I'm in front of you.
I don't want to trivialize what this is
- Listen
you're paying me a nice compliment
I appreciate it.
- When I watch you on YouTube, I feel like
that's a much smarter version of
- I gotta tell you man,
intent is a big fucker.
My big
I'm trying to really understand intent.
Because I know that
do you know how unbeatable I feel?
I will make a lot of mistakes but, fuck!
I have zero negative intent, friction.
It's all just friction.
It's why voice, it's
why I will push you guys
all for voice,
you can reach more veterans through voice
over the next five years
than anything else.
You gotta win now, build,
'cause it's friction.
Like I bought something
today in my shower!
I have Alexa now in my bathroom,
'cause it's like literally the only
outside my bed, my bathroom's
the only place I'm in and
I'm never in my own home.
I literally thought of
something and I open the door
I'm like, Alexa.
I think that
I think that this is a
super interesting time
and I think that there's
so much opportunity,
so much underpriced and
overpriced attention
and executing is just like
unbelievably important.
- [Female] Hey!
- [Gary V] Hey.
- [Female] How are you?
- [Gary V] Good, how are you?
- Great, come on in!
- Thank you so much!
Good to see you, thanks for coming!
- [Gary V] Good to see you, of course.
- Yeah.
- 'Sup man!
- [Gary V] What's up, brother?
- Thanks for coming!
- Happy to be here,
how are you?
- Good, good, welcome!
- Good to see you
- Nice to meet you.
- This is awesome!
I love it!
- What's up, Gary?
- What's up, man?
How are you?
Such a pleasure, good to see you brother.
- [Female] Come on in,
we're live already, so
do you want a water or anything?
- [Gary V] Water would be amazing.
- We have some special guest here today.
It is, my wife, Alexa
(laughs)
And
(drumroll tapping on desk)
last but not least we have
Gary Vee in the house!
Welcome to Coral Sword, my man!
- Dude, welcome!
- Thank you thank you thank you!
- Yes!
- For me, I want legacy.
I want all these people with their handles
to think I'm great, to come to my funeral,
to thank me on email one day,
to hang out with me in VR in 17 years.
Because I brought them some value.
I come on here tonight, it's late,
I've had a long fuckin' day,
we obviously ran late for
the thing that I was doing.
First of all, thank you for waiting.
I apologize to anybody
who I was making wait.
But this was like,
Baban's like, get outta here,
we gotta go to the next thing.
And the whole time, I'm like,
I'm gonna come on
and then I come on and the lights are on,
and the only thing that's
running through my mind is
fuck, I better say something that brings
some kid some value in St. Louis
who actually hears it
a different way from me
for the first time,
and goes out and actually
does something about it.
I feel responsible.
I'm thankful for the attention,
and I want to bring value.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
Now if you really heard what he just said,
there's a very powerful
secret in what you just said.
You care about what you're giving,
you have an intention to benefit,
to look for win-win.
It's so deep and it rings so true to me.
I want to tell you, just because
'cause we came in a
whirlwind and we rushed you
on the stage and thank you so much.
Like, you're a warrior for doing that.
You just were like, give me a LaCroix,
(laughs)
put the lights on,
put the chat on, let's go.
Like, beast mode.
And I know you've had a long day
and you didn't have to come here.
But I want to also tell you that
I read, I'm a searcher
and I agree with you a thousand percent,
it doesn't matter
I call it infinite patience.
I am gonna be infinitely patient
when I lose, I just got better.
I love that you're firing me up right now
but you wrote one thing
that I will never forget.
And it was, it was about
I'm tired of people saying
'thank God it's Friday'.
- If you live for the weekends,
your shit is broken.
And people get upset with me,
like, no Gary, I want to
spend time with my family,
it's not all about working
and I'm like, no no you don't understand.
- I love this.
- If you literally start
your week being sad,
and it gets progressively better,
you have a problem.
We spend way too much time in our lives
doing our jobs.
I lived that life.
You have to understand,
I'm speaking from a
place of understanding.
I lived K through 12 in that life.
I lived, I'm a huge football fan.
The fall, school started,
and I was devastated after
the Jets game was over,
I would come from a huge high,
that Sunday, 'cause I
was pumped for the Jets
to this complete depression,
because I knew that Monday
I mean, I lived for snow days
for like a decade.
(laughs)
Like for a decade, the only
thing I gave a fuck about
was, please, can a nor-easter come through
and eliminate school?
(laughs)
- Right?
- I hated school
- I used to think
the same thing.
- Right?
- Snow days were awesome.
I mean, at school you're forced into.
- Yeah.
- But now, I don't.
And I'm like, my God,
do people really have jobs
the way I lived school?
Oh my God, most people do.
- Yeah.
- And that's
by the way, random thought,
breaking news, I'm
starting a Twitch channel.
- Yes!
- Wooo, yes!
- Are you kidding me?!
- Yeeeesss!
- Where can I find you?!
- I've been thinking about
this for like two years now,
maybe even three,
like Justin hit me up like fuckin'
I've been thinking about this
for like three or four years.
But here's what I have to do.
This is such
you know why I haven't done it?
I've done plenty of
Twitch stuff and hung out.
This is such a good set up,
I'm like, wait a minute,
why don't I turn my whole
office into a Twitch
- Why not?
I know who can build it.
- Who?
- We have someone.
- We have the master.
- We have it,
we'll give you his number.
- Is his name Rick?
- No.
- Sally?
- Sean?
- No.
- Sean Mendes has been
playing the same song
for three years in a row,
and I think it's weird.
Can we talk about this?
- Who the hell is Sean?
What are you talkin' about?
- He's this great, by the way,
he's a really good kid,
from what everything I know
but he's been playing the same song
for three years, and it freaks me out.
Three fucking new years in a row,
Sean Mendes is on one of
the mainstream channels,
singing that fuckin' song.
- Yeah.
- Do you know what I'm talking about?
- I don't know who this guy is.
- Baban,
can you guys fuckin' help
me get the chat, chat
can you guys agree with me?
Chat,
can you help me in this?
- Do you guys know who he is?
- His intro song?
- No he's like
Sean Mendes is like a
fuckin' huge fuckin' kid
he's like a good looking kid.
He's a singer, he's like nice boy
but he plays the fuckin' song.
And I'm like, I feel like
I'm living in Bizarro World
because he's like SNL,
and fuckin' New Years Eve,
and I'm like, didn't
he play that last year,
and that's fine, 'cause you
know how mainstream media
is weird and they're onto
shit that's been around
for a year.
But he's been doing it for three years.
- [Female] Same thing.
- You agree, right?
I'm right, right?
- I guess if it's working.
- [Female] Stiches.
- Stitches!
Fuckin' Stitches!
Temporary's right.
Temporary Jerry.
So this guy's short, annoying,
has terrible taste in musing,
we're all really gonna make millions.
See this is the part
that I like the most.
- I love this guy.
- No no really, I like Temporary Jerry
don't ban him, 'cause
I saw you ban somebody.
I love him.
Because this is the part
that I love the most, right?
For me, it's
this is why I think I'd be a
good baseball player, right?
Because in baseball, if you're
out seven out of 10 times,
you're fucking rolling.
Right?
- Hall of Famer.
- That's right.
It's weird to me that that excites me
so much
- When people doubt you?
- I love it.
I love it.
- I feed off of that too.
- You do, right?
- I feed off it so hard,
you tell me I can't
- I really needed
to hear that message
- You did, right?
- I needed that message tonight.
- See you just helped another person.
- Yeah, thank you.
- Look
- You came out here
and you helped me.
- Listen, you have a different dynamic.
We have our dynamics,
and what have you.
Put ourselves out there, we're out there.
Pretty girls have a whole 'nother layer.
- Yeah.
- Whole different.
But it's still the same game,
which is you're either
inside your own head
or you're not.
Right?
That feeds me,
as much as somebody who says
I'm the best or I'm the G.O.A.T.
And all that.
They all feed me weirdly the same way.
And I like it and I really
am trying to figure out
how to teach kids that.
Because there's a lot of
kids who aren't putting out
great content, aren't enjoying themselves,
aren't living.
Because they can't deal
with temporary Jerry55
saying that you're short,
you're ugly, you're fat,
you're stupid, you suck, fuck you.
And I'm trying to figure out
why do I hear that and say
two things which is like,
fuck,
I feel bad for temporary Jerry, like why
he must be in pain and I'd
like to become his friend
and make him awesome.
And two, fuck you, temporary Jerry,
motherfucker.
I'm gonna stick it in your fuckin' mouth
and I can't wait to meet you one day,
temporary fuckin' Jerry
and you're gonna be like,
yo I'm temporary Jerry I'm sorry.
- I love you Jerry.
- I like it!
- You know?
- Yeah.
I'm reading his stuff,
what does this have to
do with the fact that
- I think it's about time
to wrap this up though
but we want to
- It's true, I'm supposed
to leave like a fuckin'
hour ago, why am I even here, Baban?
Get me the fuck out of here, bro!
What are you doing?
- Why are you leavin' him hangin' man?
- Dude, he's just like,
this is great for the vlog,
and I'm like,
I have to wake up in like an hour.
Fuck me!
Get me out of here, what?!
- Last thing,
let's hear about your book!
- It's really good.
Guys, you guys are smart.
Don't buy it, go steal
it off of Bit Torrent
and read it, and fuckin'
figure out how great it is,
because this is the greatest era to
talk about shit you love
and that's what I'd like you to do.
I'd really like you to read it.
Library, Bit Torrent, don't buy it,
I don't need it.
I just really need you to understand
what's actually fucking happening.
And what's actually happening is
the middleman is going away,
there are no gatekeepers.
It is you and the audience.
You need to talk about what you love,
'cause everything else
is too hard of work.
And if you're talented enough
and what you love is interesting enough,
you'll make between $1 a year and
fuckin' $40 million.
The fuckin' end.
(modern hip hop music)